welcome back to uncensored by P with me
the Socialist North Grace blin talk to
contributor Esther KY right so Grace
this is horrendous what happened was
horrendous the retribution is going to
be horrendous this spiral of violence
continues what do you make of this what
I make of it is that the violence that
we're seeing at the moment is you know
put in place and encouraged by the fact
that there is so little knowledge and
understanding of what is going on in
Palestine and the crimes that are being
committed there every day if like me you
know people in Palestine you know
journalists working in Palestine you
know uh human rights organizations
working there your news feed every day
will be full of videos of um isra of
Israeli troops harming civilians killing
children often we know that
6,400 Palestinians have been killed
since 2008 nothing nothing justifies the
scale of this this is Isis level
terrorism what you're saying not just a
Revenge attack here when you put to me a
question like that it's the equivalent
of saying you know there's a man who's
in a house he's got his whole family
there another guy comes in kicks him out
of his house locks him in the cellar
kills his family says you're not coming
out all of his neighbors say oh yeah
you're right to keep him in there and
just ignore the situation suddenly the
man comes up busts out says I'm you know
I'm G to get rid of of all of this stuff
and burning the house down lots of
people die and then the only way that
you look at situation is by saying oh
let's condemn the man in the cell yes
condemn the man in the cell but K you
have to look at what is in the best
interest of innocent Palestinians that
are not reacting in this way I'm not
disputing the fact that obviously there
is a lot wrong with the situation
between Israel and Palestine but the
idea that you know by attacking by
murdering 700 Israeli citizens 900 now
well 900 now you're you're inherently
acting in the best interest of innocent
who I I I I've often said I absolutely
I'm I'm horrified by the applying over
half of the population of Palestine is
under the age of 25 and entire
generation this is all they've ever the
problem is Hamas are annihilist Terror
organization
EMP have been empowered by the collapse
of the center ground and why has that
happened that has been aided and abetted
by this astonishingly right-wing
conservative government that we've seen
in Israel can I can agree with that and
when interviewed n i put that to him I
can agree with that there are lots of
issues there the social unrest in Israel
because of their attempts to try and
basically diminish the suprem cour
saying the Israeli intelligence services
are saying we have been warning you the
Israeli government that if you continue
to allow Israeli settlers to murder
Palestinian this will cause a security
threat and now people are saying this
Chicken and the Egg I just don't think
anyone on a day like this can start
getting into the other stuff so quickly
before you say this is disgusting what
makes me so sad is that of course it's
disgusting but there are so many abuses
and violations and just horrible an
Israeli child shot in the back running
away from Israeli forces after been
throwing rocks that literally just
happened recently
do where would you the responsibility of
Iran because Iran clearly clearly funded
Iran is clearly funding lot this exactly
responsibity a lot of the show on on
this issue it's not going to go away
this will be raging now for weeks months
um I fear
years